talk about dilemma which is part of your
tools yeah and that would be pretty much
what I go to next
because the way that I work with dilemma
is
I'm looking at that
right from the outset
in developing the story like you can see
that even as I'm
playing with this
Broad
array of possibilities for this story I
keep coming back to well if the robot
had been programmed to do this and you
know like what's unacceptable to the
robot and what might be equally
unacceptable and
you know how does that
how is that impacted by commands that
are given by the robot's operating
system
um
by the robots sense of morality
one of my favorite quotes which I
thought about for a flickering second
about a half an hour ago
it's by a writer George Saunders
and he says um
character is the governing element
of life and is above genius
and
real character
is something that's very important
and mere genius is just some other smart
dude who could be completely crazy
but he's wicked smart and it's like but
he's destructive or you know it's like
it's it's just genius that you know it
kind of like throw a stick and you can
hit a genius but half of them are
screwed up
you know character is is substantial and
that could be
something that the robot is really
wrestling with
and I really like the the image of data
the character
who's
I think it had a positronic brain it was
absolute state-of-the-art computer
technology
built into an Android I don't know if it
synthesized human and robot or if it's
just
a pure
machine
but his hunger
for Humanity and curiosity about
aspects and foibles of
humanity is
intriguing it was something I haven't
seen that show in many many years but I
always liked
data
and I remember one show he even became
human for
a half an hour in the Holo deck or
something like that
but at the end of it all
he understands what a joke is and he's
like oh that's funny even though he's no
longer in the mindset that had him
acting really like a human Spock did
that sometimes too
where he would become more like a an
impulsive wild animal than a rigidly
controlled logician
and he'd you know go into these
different states and be goofy and wacky
and funny and all that stuff
so just in terms of
focusing on trapping this
or automaton in a dilemma of magnitude a
dilemma that matters to the audience
there's a lot of raw material for that
here
and
it seems as though
there might be altruism on one side like
it's unacceptable to give up
a sense of what's right of doing the
right thing of being able to be
incapable
of doing
really powerful
world-changing things
someone who's kind of like was raised to
be a brain surgeon and like they're
really trying to do good for people and
that's built into who they are and
why
they operate
so that's an interesting
thing to kind of
just sit there and let it float like the
need to do good a moral compass and even
just a moral compass
knowing what's right and what's wrong
um
so then to countermand that or to be the
opposite of that but equal because you
want equally unacceptable Alternatives
that's where you get that Robbie the
robot short circuiting in between two
things if one
if one side of the other of the Dilemma
is more unacceptable than the other than
you have a path of least resistance and
electricity will always take the path of
least resistance but if you have equal
resistance then you block it you have
impedance and it heats up
and electricity so
I know what this automaton looks like
caught in this dilemma
because it looks literally like Robbie
the robot short circuiting
like it can't it's like
unable to process command
and so I know that I want to achieve
that but it's a question of what are
the two Alternatives that are being
sort of not just posed to this automaton
but sort of foisted onto this but
automaton forced like Sophie's Choice
it's not like oh that'll be a fun Choice
which kid do I sacrifice it's horrible
it's
like I don't want any of this
but it may not be that extreme but we
want something
substantial of magnitude that
really impacts an audience
and you want not only magnitude a
dilemma that matters to the audience
but you want it to where
the audience can
relate to it personally
and that's
an important aspect of working with
dilemma because if you're
trapping a protagonist in a dilemma
and the average person in the audience
can understand it intellectually
but has no emotional connection to it
then they're like I see what they're
talking about but I don't care
so one of the questions I'm always
asking my students is once you have a
dilemma trapped
between two equally unacceptable
alternatives
can the average member of the audience
connect to that
and so what I say is like you know pick
somebody who like lives down the street
that you don't even know and sort of
study them indirectly you know they
might be someone who's like you know a
graduate student in dance and really
creative and drives Uber at night to
make ends meet and it's just a regular
person down the street
so you've got your character trapped in
this dilemma can that person down the
street that you don't really know or
don't know at all can they connect to
that or is it like because you want your
average member of the audience who's
just a plumber taking his kids to the
movie or whatever
do they see themselves in it
because if they don't then
they're less connected to it and they
say that the deeper you go the more
Universal you get
so
if the movie you know is about
you know a contractor in France who's
caught up in a tricky situation
it should be so that like
you know a doctor in Australia can watch
that movie and go I don't know anything
about building houses
but his dilemma of like Duty versus
honor or something like that like I can
totally relate to that so it's like
what we want as we
work with developing a dilemma for this
automaton
is to make it so that the average member
of the audience
looks at that dilemma and goes wow I'm
caught in the same dilemma it's a
different set of circumstances but I'm
caught in that exact same thing and I
don't know how to get out of it maybe
this robot can solve the thing that's
paralyzing me in a fundamental way
then the audience cares that much more
and it's a visceral connection it's an
emotional connection not just an
intellectual understanding it's
interesting to try to
trap this robot in a real quandary they
do a decent job of that in the Will
Smith movie Eye robot Will Smith hates
robots because they tore off his arm at
one point he's a cop
the head of this huge corporation gets
thrown off a 30-story landing
and Will Smith is brought in to
investigate and everybody thinks
this robot
killed the master
but and Will Smith hates that suspect
robot from the beginning because he's
prejudiced against all robots he hates
them all
but he begins to perceive that the robot
that is under suspicion
has unique insights and is
the total opposite of what he thought
and it's at the and that robot was
actually reprogrammed by the old man
before he was killed
and that robot is there to help Will
Smith stop the robot Corporation from
doing something treacherous
I don't remember exactly what it was I
think it's a robot army that they're
unleashing on the World to control them
but it's interesting because
because that robot
is either raising interesting questions
in Will Smith's mind or Will Smith is
Raising interesting questions in the
robot's mind
I can't recall but
that's just a movie I've seen that has
similarities to this type of
potential story
and
like I can feel the presence of the
Dilemma even if I'm not able to
articulate it clearly at this point
because I'm still kind of inventing what
these two
equally unacceptable Alternatives could
be but I know
I know how that robot feels trapped in
that type of situation
I have an emotional connection to what
that does to this robot
and
so as I sort of try to conjure what
these things might be
it can be helpful
to look ahead
to the point of Crisis where the Dilemma
comes to a critical juncture around the
three-quarters point in the movie around
the end of act two
because we want the Dilemma to kick in
somewhere around the end of act one
where we've we've gotten to know the
main character the stories developed
and as as the story gets up to speed
like the full complexity the story is
All kicking in
we want this robot to be trapped
in this dilemma of magnitude either
before the end of act one or by the end
of act one and we want that Dilemma to
extend throughout act two
where
The Dilemma goes critical
prior to that the robot is like I can't
pick in either direction and the same
with Jay Coit in Training Day I can't
let go of this opportunity but I can't
do what Alonso is trying to get me to do
uh
and so
that dilemma is going to go critical
around the end of act two
and then the protagonist has to make a
decision
about the dilemma and take an action
about it now that it's gone critical and
then the ending of the story is the
resolution of the Dilemma the active
resolution of the Dilemma by the
protagonist that conclusively resolves
the Dilemma
so the Dilemma is like fully engaged
before the end of act one or around the
end of Act One it builds an intensity
all throughout act two
to the point where it reaches this
critical juncture that forces the
protagonist to make a decision and take
an action about the Dilemma that he or
she couldn't previously decide about and
then the end is the resolution of the
Dilemma so the Dilemma encompasses
most of the proportion of the script
it's not something that happens for five
minutes in the story it's something that
takes up most of the story and if you
look at the movie
um
Almost Famous by Cameron Crowe he won
best screenplay for that
he said
the the kid who's the reporter
he
he re he can't become friends with the
band because then he's no longer an
objective reporter
and if he does become friends with them
they'll try to make him write about how
cool they are
so he he loves this band it's
unacceptable to not become friends with
them because they're the coolest
creatures around and he's uncool so he's
desperate for that
and yet his mentor the Philip Seymour
Hoffman character says do not become
their friend because they'll make you
into a puppet and write about how great
they are you want to be an objective
reporter and really stick to your guns
on that
and Cameron Crowe said that dilemma is
what the movie's about
and if you look at it again you can see
that constitutes the full proportion of
the script
it takes a little bit of time of setup
to get to get to know him he gets in
with the band starts traveling with him
but after he's really in there he has
great opportunities to become friends
with them but he really wants to be a
good reporter
so the Dilemma is
constitutes much of the proportion of
the script and the way I describe it
sometimes is like it's like a whale in
your living room it doesn't take up
every square inch but it takes up the
full thing you can still walk around it
and stuff but it's not a little thing in
the middle of your living room it's the
Dilemma is
constitutes the full proportion of the
script
so all of that to say that as I work to
conjure what these two equally
unacceptable Alternatives could be that
paralyze the protagonist for much of the
script
one way to
um
see what these might be more clearly is
to look ahead to the point of crisis
like okay so at some point this dilemma
is going to come to a make or break
point which is very much the gun to the
head on the protagonist like you don't
get to spend any more time thinking
about how you're gonna what kind of
decision you're gonna make about this
dilemma you have to decide now that's
the nature of a crisis it demands
immediate decision and action
and so
sometimes looking ahead to what the
crisis might look like
can help you see what this is by sort of
looking through the opposite end of the
telescope or seeing it from a different
point so if I'm this robot and I'm
trapped and I can really feel these
things I just don't know exactly what
they are yet and that's okay
but at some point
there's going to be a make or break
crisis about this dilemma
yeah and it's really about morality like
versus
ambition I think
like if the son of the leader is going
to make eight trillion dollars
overnight
I can see the robot
feeling morality
but does a robot have that type of
ambition
like does it care
about
eight trillion dollars I don't know I
mean like I have 13 year old girls
and they're very aware of money now and
like it and are interested but you know
when they're eight you know they get
Christmas money or and we like put it on
their desk and they like didn't pay any
attention to we'd find it like you know
under a book the next week or they just
they didn't it didn't mean anything to
them yet
so like
to what degree might an automaton value
this
massive amplification of power and
possibility
and all that
and certainly if it's an AI
then it could certainly have been imbued
with
characteristics of the owner that
growing the company is really important
and is important to the survival of the
business even survival of the automaton
if the business got shut down then maybe
the plug gets pulled on the Autumn on
the automaton
but it seems as though like
being
raised by the owner
programmed or created
I don't know if the money is as
important as the
capability
you know so is the
is the Sun
telling the robot look
some people are gonna die in the process
of this or maybe the robot comes back
and says you know this plan you're
putting in place a whole lot of people
are going to die
and you know maybe the robot hadn't
really connected that yet
and the owner is like well yeah but that
you know that's how progress is often
made
and the thing is that
if our company
achieves this Monopoly
then
our capability to help so many more
people and
in other words appeal to the altruism of
the robot or the moral compass or
something like that
is possible
and you can see I'm just kind of feeling
my way along with it
and you know I'm not even sure what an
ambitious robot
even looks like
but it's programming it's compulsion
it's
you know like not so much more is better
but more enables
more function more capability more
something
it's puzzling like I'm not sure
so
but so I'm not exactly sure what the
crisis is but I can see a sense of what
decision and action in the face of
Crisis might look like
because the the crisis breaks the
paralysis of the Dilemma
it forces a decision and action
and they say uh
Aristotle said that decision and action
in the face of Crisis reveals the true
character it strips the mask off you
like you don't know who your real
friends are until you've been through a
crisis with them the classic example is
the big strong guy jumps up and runs out
screaming the little guy jumps up and
Saves the Day
so you don't know what people are really
made of until they're forced by a crisis
to show what they're really made of and
I could see the robot really trying to
do the right thing at the point of
crisis
but to get to the resolution which is
the resolution the conclusive proactive
resolution of the Dilemma by the
protagonist
once the
robot
takes a stand to try to do the right
thing at the critical moment
then he's got to fight to the finish
with the Sun
to get through the last 15 minutes of
this movie in a real knock down drag out
fight that the robot May well lose
uh
and there could certainly be a creative
resolution for the automaton but it's
going to have to grow and
think differently and
disobey key things and
cleave more closely to key things
some values that it's been programmed to
value
to to you know uphold
will be shattered and some values that
has been programmed to
want will be Amplified as the way the
way people do in real life so
the one thing that's really crystalline
is decision in action I can see the
robot is really going to try to do the
right thing
um
so does that inform
what the Dilemma consists of
let me just sure and I just thought of
something too that might be driving the
sun aside from money and that is
notoriety and fame that will come with
the you know and he's the the the son of
this sort of brainchild and then you
know he's the
you know he maybe social media wasn't
around when the father was building the
company and now maybe the sun is not 30
yet and now he'll be the you know
successful 30 under 30 and so there's
all this uh you know press that he wants
and that's also driving him yeah you
know which is also kind of Madness and
sure that kind of stuff the narcissism
and the the need for power and maybe the
father was never around because he was
just working 19 hours a day and the kid
has a
you know a sort of out of proportion
need to be loved or to impress or to be
validated
and he had his whole identity was um I
mean growing up in the Bay Area I knew
people that their children were you know
from someone's owned a tech company and
that was the first thing out of their
mouth and and you know wasn't always the
healthiest Dynamics but it was high and
my father was so and so and I think
that's a very real thing and
unfortunately it just happens absolutely
so uh you know maybe he needs that it's
driving him and also the social media
accolades and the press to be in all of
the financial papers as yeah absolutely
yeah you know and we want to build
complexity into that but that's where
the Enneagram is so useful
to dimensionalize that sun in a way
where you understand the Sun
but you still see him as a monster but
he still has very interesting aspects
and
um
you know you see
up and coming business owners who are
really ruthless with their competitors
and then after they make it big they're
like giving money away to everybody but
they destroyed multiple businesses to
get there
so it's like you know
again again it's the the ambition versus
moral compass type thing
now
the other interesting model for dilemma
to try on
is something that comes from
my knowledge of Tootsie
which is that
Michael dorsey's uh a male actor who's
very talented actor but a huge pain in
the ass to work with and he's
really
inept at relating to women
um
and when he dresses up as a woman and
gets hired
all of a sudden he's got a career of fat
paycheck respect as an actor
and relationships with women that he
wasn't capable of doing as Michael now
that he's Dorothy and he sees women from
a totally different point of view now
that he's Dorothy and he becomes Dorothy
becomes a crusader for women's rights
whereas Michael was kind of the person
she'd be crusading against
so
and and there's all kinds of ways in
which becoming Dorothy is disrupting
Michael's life
in both major and minor ways
so
Michael can't let go of Dorothy because
it's the best thing that ever happened
to him but he can't keep
being her because it's the worst thing
that ever happened to him and it kind of
cooked down to like
Dorothy is creating him like literally
making him a better person and
destroying him like kind of taking him
apart as all these things happen
so I'm like I want to like try that on
for a possibility for this automaton is
there a way that this situation
is offering a lot of
potential upscale
to the robot and yet is also destroying
now here's something that could actually
drive a robot or give a robot ambition
so
what if
we talked about the possibility of the
robot regenerating the old man in
humanoid form even if it only is 20
minutes
based on sneaking around to use the
equipment in the in the manufacturing
facility kind of like you know the
Tyrell Corporation where they can make
people
um
could the Sun
tell the automaton
stick with me and help me pull this off
we'll make eight trillion dollars
overnight we'll be worth 80 trillion
this time next year and we'll be getting
up towards a quadrillion in five years
like
boom like
we can now move on to the master plan of
actually
genetically
building
people so you the automaton could have a
human body and actually walk around and
get cut and have Bo and go surfing and
you know get sunburned like all the
things that you've always wanted see
that's something that could really like
the robot is like
I want that and almost like an out of
proportion irrational like I'm desperate
to have that nothing's going to make me
let go of that but I'm also being asked
to look
help
execute a billion people with this
contagion
so that we can sell the cure for it
and that's going to make me human and so
see how I was like I was feeling around
for how can a robot be ambitious what
does he care about does money mean
anything at all to him
but that like that's something
and it's you know it's
Pinocchio you know the the wants to be a
real boy
um
and it Taps into Data
and
it doesn't have to
it doesn't have to come from a
place that necessarily makes sense from
the outside
so it's not you look at that from
outside and be like
no that's way more killing a billion
people is way more unacceptable than not
becoming human
but if we're dealing with like Madness
to some degree
this outsized hunger in this automaton
to be human that it's irrational
but it's extremely real for this
automaton it is a really deep need that
really drives this
machine
that probably has a soul
a conscience or
a personality
soul is such an ambiguous word
but um
something that might
emulate
human personality quite well so it's not
missing that
but it wants a human body
quite a lot and
the sun could even
influence
the automatons operating system like
with a virus that makes it like more
greedy to be human sort of take that
irrational
drive and
amplify it
um
see now there's see how I was like I'm
not sure what these are there's
something there's one of them right
there
and
yes it's a real challenge to like for
this one main creature that we like and
are rooting for to really want that we
can we can get behind that but when we
look at it
becoming human versus helping kill a
billion people where it has to be
handled right so that we keep rooting
for this Android
because that if
if the Android starts going home Diddy I
can't wait to kill a billion people and
eat hot dogs on the beach we're like
I'm not rooting for this creature
anymore you know it's like you have to
get the audience sympathy or I think the
better word is empathy because it's not
like pity sympathy and Furs pity but
audience empathy like they're really
rooting for this character you have to
get the audience empathy and keep it
you can get it and then lose it if you
don't handle it right so this has to be
handled right
so that the need to become human
has some kind of perceived
equalness in the mind of this automaton
based on this automaton's skewed
perception of the world
um
like think of all the things you can do
in a body first of all maybe that body
won't age you know we're going to put
you in a body but 400 years from now
it'll still be 27 and you'll still be
the the best surfer on the beach and
like whatever and you can be brain sir
you can you can you can change the face
you're designed to change the face of
humanity even
you know and these billion people who
are going to die
they're already starving they're not
going to live that much longer they're
sickly they're in you know it's like
the more that
the sun can amplify
the capabilities of this AI put on a
human body that can
you know last a thousand years versus
the fate of these people who are already
gonna die anyway it's like it's like
getting somebody with terminal cancer
and sending them in as a suicide bomber
it's like there's people that will sign
up for that
so if he has to sacrifice people that
are demonstratively not going to live
that long anyway then and he's like I
can help the other seven billion people
who really need my capabilities as a
master healer
10 years from now and I've really
Incorporated so much more with with all
the wealth that this company can do
then you begin to it's not like so
wildly uneven from this automaton's
point of view even though we can still
go don't be an idiot you're still
killing a billion people but I think
that's also what he's going to discover
at the point of crisis
like that the sun's been radically lying
to him
or something like that or they
you know the old man who's back as a
human for 20 minutes or whatever is like
he's lying his ass off to you just like
he always did to me he's a monster don't
let him get away with this
and then maybe you know the son comes in
and kills the father again like right
who knows but um
we have now the elements of a dilemma
that have to be managed right
but the Deep hunger to become human
and be a savior in many ways like an
Intelligence on an order of magnitude
Beyond
any human that ever lived in a human
body that
I mean obviously if you like you know
you can chainsaw it in half but it's not
gonna
die from a cold or age or those kind of
things
and it's it's interesting and it goes
back to the um
the trick of how they catch monkeys in
the Philippines which is that they take
a coconut Hollow it out make a hole the
size of a monkey's hand and put rice
inside it tie it to a tree the monkey
comes along reaches in there and grabs
the rice but holding the rice it can't
get its hand back out
and the way they catch it is they just
walk up to the monkey and grab it and
it's screaming its head off it wants to
run but it will not let go of the rice
like this Android is like I want life
it's just like what Roy Batty says to
Deckard I want more life father
um
so that's interesting
and
if the Android has been infected with a
virus by the Sun
that weakens its
moral compass its ethics its
then there's more gray area and less
black and white inside that Androids
ethical Choice system
like where it's starting to agree with
the sun yeah you know I could see where
300 million of those people are
literally going to be dead in a week
anyway so that doesn't mess up my
Android conscience and
you know it's like he's able to
rationalize
which is weird to say for a robot but
the more human they become the more
they get better at rationalization and I
don't remember what movie it was
might have been Kiss Kiss Bang Bang
like did you ever try to go a day
without a rationalization
something like that that it's key to how
people operate and from my own study of
Hamlet which I was trained on
um
the thing that I found about Hamlet the
more I studied it
was that there was a huge discrepancy
between what he says he's going to do
which is everything
and what he actually does which is
virtually nothing is what gets him in
the whole royal family killed
because his the ghost of his father says
your uncle killed me go kill him and
make things right and Hamlet who's a
Crown Prince who's been raised as a man
of action
that comes right to the front he says
Absolutely I'll go kill him no problem
but then the more he thinks about it
he's like was that a trick of the devil
and he's off it
College studying philosophy chasing
girls sword fighting riding horses he
has an ideal life and he's like do I
really want to give all that up to kill
my uncle and become king and be stuck in
this cold castle with all these shallow
backstabbing people around
and so
when it comes time to take action
he's not sure if he should and he lets
the chance go by him and then he beats
up on himself he's like oh I should have
just done it all right so next time next
chance boy am I going to do it
and then he doesn't do it again but he
is asking all the right questions
but the next chance he gets to do it he
doesn't and then he's really angry he's
like okay now next time watch out I'm
gonna go crazy I'm really mad now
nothing's gonna stop me and he screws up
yet again and so the discrepancy between
what he says he's going to do which is
everything and what he actually does
which is practically nothing
comes down to his ability to lie to
himself it's about self-deception
because he believes it when he says next
time I'm really going to do it
but he's lying to himself and
the more I studied Hamlet the more I
grew to hate him because he's really a
screw-up like literally a royal screw-up
and
he's unable to take decisive action in
the face of an emergency and that's why
the whole family ends up dying but his
self-deception is the mechanism by which
he does that
and everybody has self-deception in
varying degrees and the more that I
studied Hamlet and the more I grew to
hate him because I see him as an abject
screw-up
who can't communicate honestly with
himself
so if I notice like oh I'm talking about
I'm doing this and doing this but I'm
not actually doing it I'm like I'm doing
a hamlet so get rid of the crap and just
do it or whatever but be honest with
yourself
and so
it brings up an interesting question of
like self-deception
in a robot as it becomes more human it's
able to lie to itself to help itself get
where it needs to it's like a negative
aspect of becoming human
so that's intriguing and it's a it's an
interesting dynamic in the story and
something that the sun might be able to
amplify by the introduction of a virus
that's sort of corroding or corrupting
his rigid
ethics like Robbie the robot cannot
disobey an order and cannot harm a human
being
you know if one of those things was
being corrupted then maybe sort of could
disobey a command or something like that
it's it's an interesting
thing to play with
so
we still don't have
a whole lot of particulars yet but we
have a whole lot more than we did 45
minutes ago
and the 36 dramatic situations just like
as I looked at ambition I'm like so
obviously
the son who we may not have invented by
that at that point the sun could be
extremely ambitious 8 billion eight
trillion dollars overnight what's not to
like and all that stuff and could the
robot have ambition and how does a robot
have ambition and
you know what are the Ambitions of the
founding father or something like that
but you could see how just
thinking about an automaton need to
steal medicine
innocent will suffer treachery and Glory
wish granting
looking at ambition through the lens of
the lenses of those
raw elements gave rise to several
possibilities and really there was you
know hundreds of possibilities in on in
that
but several about ambition jumped right
out and grabbed me by the throat
ambition by the protagonist the
automaton or ambition by the central
villain the Sun
and that gave us
like something to actually grab onto
instead of just smoking a bucket where
there wasn't really anything you could
grab yet
now we're beginning to have some things
out of which you can Cobble together a
story and we've gradually been
possibilities have been gelling a few
things have started to really solidify
decision and action even kind of
crystallizes like I could really see
that as a hard real thing I don't know
what the resolution might be
I'm getting more of a sense well now
that we have the possibility of him
becoming human and he's like
irrationally over attracted to that
that can counterbalance the
unacceptability of sacrificing a billion
people who were gonna die anyway in
other words it's the ability to lie to
yourself and the virus makes him more
manipulable and less rigid
you know it's like when Spock you know
gets some alien fungus and he's laying
around like he's on catnip instead of
going that's not logical
you know so we're like playing with
interesting things and
creating plot devices like
corrupting part of the robot's operating
system with a virus
makes certain things that we're trying
to do more tangible and doable
rather than I wish we could had a way to
corrupt his operating system that kind
of thing